today's episode brought to you by liquid
death
god kill it
today's guests are um you know they're
those front line tongue ninjas baby you
know what i'm saying
uh i mean these guys are you know the uh
the the senseis of selling they're a
father and son
duo from san marcos texas
they work in a business that i know
nothing about but i'm very curious to
learn
today's guest we are very honored to
have in studio it is cameron
and his father spanky nichols and they
are
auctioneers
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
nashville is a cool spot man first time
here is your first time here yeah
yeah my first time too okay very cool
spot and you've been sober ever since
no i haven't been sober ever since i've
had a couple relapses here and there
uh well but every day is a work in
progress
yeah it really is dude i'm grateful just
have each new day you know and just try
to have a good attitude when i get up
right yeah if i can start out decent i
usually do pretty well
yeah it's when i start yeah so you don't
want to go have a drink with me later
probably not man i'll watch you drink
dude hell i'll buy you some steroids
dude
we used to do a good bit of uh you know
one of my buddies one night we were i
was doing some touring somewhere and um
he's like it's like 3 a.m he's like hey
man i'm going to get some drugs you know
give me some money and i was like all
right you know i'm not going out there
to get them but i'll
you know what i'm saying i'll be a part
of it fiscally i'll be up
involved yeah right right so i give him
some money and then he comes back like
two hours later man he had steroids on
him he's like let's barter
and he had injectable steroids man i
said well
it takes two weeks to get in your system
yeah so even if we do them right now we
gotta
you know say i gotta get a gym
membership and then you and i gotta meet
back up in a couple weeks
so this wasn't a good idea so we decided
not funny story though
i'm sitting here with cam and spanky and
you guys are auctioneer men right
that is correct and is that a a safe
term what is the term
to to to to reference somebody that does
auction auctioneer
that's it yes sir the old school term
would be colonel
colonel really in world war one the the
all the the the colonels when they got
done with all the equipment they were
the ones that sold the equipment
so they labeled auctioneers as colonels
horses too oh really so they had to get
them to listen to them so they gave them
the the title colonel just so to get the
men to listen to him
they gave him the title colonel so then
the men had to listen and so at the end
of like a battle or something or a war
sometimes the colonel would auction off
the gear
i think so to my understanding horses
and gear yeah
so technically we are colonels okay and
so
i think technically and you guys so
spanky you got into it first
yes sir okay and so how did that occur
how did you
how do you just how does someone become
an auctioneer
it's really uh uh it's a family
passed down trait i mean it's tough to
get it it's
really really tough to break into like
like they'll tell you
five percent of every graduating
auctioneer class
only five percent ever pursue it and
make a living at doing it
and is that uh and is it because it's a
family business like it's hard
it's not necessarily a family business
but it's it's more so
of uh with anything it's who you know
right versus what you know correct yeah
and that's everything i mean and even
actually in
i know in louisiana there's a lot of
barge captains and stuff like that
in that business it tugboat captains
yeah and that is a
familial business i mean if your
grandfather you can literally get
grandfathered into it right
you know and that's um and they're
always going to court over that over
trying to like uh
adjust the way people can get into that
um so spanky take me into how you get
into it so
my father uh graduated missouri auction
school in 1974. oh wow and he's
he's had auto auctions my whole life
owned auto auctions my whole life
and so i mean i i was working the ring
which they say the ring
is the floor taking bids yeah
yeah the floor bitters okay i mean i i
was working the ring as young as 10 11
12 years old
okay and when you're in the ring what is
that like so so the ring is the floor
where
the arena and and and working the crowd
okay
working working the people that that are
attending the auction they're
buying and bidding you're you're taking
their bids and turning them into the
auctioneer
on a block okay at that time would have
been my dad i mean we've done anything
from tool sales to
car sales mainly my dad has owned car
auto auctions my whole life
wow so uh do you remember like so as a
ring person
were there some like was that kind of
was that harder than being actually the
big boss
no not at all you don't have to count
you just have to you don't have to count
you just got to turn bids in i mean yep
yep yep yep
and every time you yep i mean you're
going up the auctioneer is going up 100
or
whatever increments he's counting okay
so
what determines uh and and what
determines how you count like how the
auctioneer sets the
like the increments how fast the crowd
is bidding right
and also there's a floor so like there's
a reserve
so if you're like ten thousand bucks you
know you're counting two fifties or
hundreds and if you're liking whatever
two or three hundred bucks it's
fifties sometimes okay whatever the
crowd will allow you to do right okay
and uh what um what are some of the
things as you're
okay so you you get out of the ring and
you end up becoming the auctioneer
so did you have to go to school for that
like and and you went to missouri
auction school missouri auction school
the same one you went to canada sir okay
same one my dad went to
okay and how many like is there like a
how big is
your was your client i think there was
like 50 of us
yeah for that year and is that pretty
competitive i mean that seems like a
competitive like you just the business
sharpening your tongue before class like
it's yeah the business is the school you
you don't come out of auction school
as an auctioneer no you come out of
auction school with the
with the ability to practice and learn
to become an auctioneer it takes years
after
taking years after i will say that he
cameron
has become the fastest auction not just
because of my son
but it comes natural to him right i have
to work a lot harder at it
he he's he's a lot more natural at it
really than a lot of people i've ever
seen and what do you what makes him what
are some of those kind of natural
abilities that make someone have an
easier
uh walk with auctioning just breathing
it just he just came real natural
to him breathing he learned uh counting
and he's a real sharp guy
on on top of aside from auctioneering
and and that's memory is a lot of of
of auctioneering i mean you gotta you
know stay on track with your numbers and
not not
miss numbers and and and counting that
at that rapid speed it takes it takes a
good memory
and he has that what do you think like
there's some of
because i i can almost relate to a
uterus pancrea when you're saying like
i don't know the pressure would max me
out dude
you know what i'm saying i'd be on
dilaudid or something i'd be on you know
what i'm saying i'd be calling big
pharma i would need
like i think the pressure like even just
in the moment of the like
keeping the tablature in my head worried
i was going to upset
people well there's there's there's a
lot going on when you're up there
auctioneering and selling cars at 30 40
seconds every car i mean you're
you're you're and nowadays with covid uh
you know
you don't have a guy sitting over here
talking to you necessarily or
sometimes you do that's a luxury
sometimes he's in the computer
and so you're watching the computer
you're watching the crowd you're
watching another screen for online
bidders
so you're watching everything at the
same time wow and you
and you're trying not to piss off eight
or ten people at one time
and keep the whole entire crowd happy
and i mean there's a lot going on when
you're up there
all right oh cam what would you say is
um is there a moment in the bidding like
in the bidding process
when what's the toughest moment for
auctioneer as the bin really gets
heightened out you know like or is it in
the beginning like
what's in the beginning taking on some
of the journey through when you start an
item
so yeah the car rolls in or the item or
whatever you're selling
and who brings it in is it women usually
yeah
usually no just random people they just
get these drivers in
oh damn i feel like you put a bait you
know you put a
beautiful little burger blender i'll buy
it yeah
yeah oh absolutely for sure it will help
i'll buy a used vacuum if she's nice
you know what i'm about that's gone by
the wayside really
you got to be politically correct
nowadays and give everybody an
opportunity
right but if some man walks out there
with a blender dude he can keep it
yeah i'm not interested you know what
i'm saying like so i mean yeah you're
giving people opportunity but you're not
giving
you're not really you know you're not
going to push my buttons i don't think
as well like
my mom when i was growing up my mom used
to deliver these magazines called news
on wheels
and it was a magazine that had pictures
of like women like
semi-lewd women kind of laying on the
hood of the
it was usually like a uh not t-mobile
what am i thinking of um
primeco uh it's like a t-mobile uh t-top
car yeah and so it like a corvette or
something you know
something that had a pack of winston's
in the dashboard you know what i'm
saying like something like that
yeah some old like and so they would
always have a lady laying on the front
oh yeah
and it would just be and that would help
sell the car oh yeah yeah absolutely
but that's advertising marketing it was
advertising yeah um
but yeah that's kind of sexist now damn
that's crazy dude
i mean i get it but also we used to have
like hooters girls come and uh serve
wings and stuff at our auction
okay so there's a little bit of like uh
it used to be today yeah yeah absolutely
right um okay so take me i'm sorry to
interrupt you cam so take me up through
some of that what's that like man once
you get the item so they kind of
do they always wheel the item out yeah
the car will come in so it's like a huge
barn with like
big bay doors and there's 18 lanes
there's
four to 18 lanes depending on what
auction we're working and they just
drive the cars through the car sits the
lanes when you say that what does that
mean i know what lane is
straight a bay okay so like a big garage
okay so like if you were to take this
garage door and open it up over here it
just goes through
auctioneer's in the middle and you got
the ring right there okay and
the car will roll up and it sits there
for until pretty much until we find
money on it which is basically get you
get a bid
okay uh i'd say the toughest part is
probably just finding the money but it's
also the easiest too because you can
just drop it really low and go
okay so a car rolls in right and
you do you start the bidding or the
audience starts the bidding we start the
bidding so
we look at our computer or if we have a
rep next to us
there'll be a reserve or a floor with
that dealer needs for that car
uh so we usually start it around there
give or take and then from there we find
the money and then we go up and
get some excitement and bids roll in now
using that beginning moment do you see
people kind of talk to their friends oh
yeah yeah we read people
we read people yeah so if you see
somebody and
i didn't mean to interrupt but they're
they're waiting for you to drop back oh
yeah back back back back and so you're
fishing
for money and so you just dropped down
in in
you know numbers so who are you working
for the seller or the bidders or you're
working for both we're working for the
auction but we really work for the
seller
okay uh in this because we're selling
his merchandise
inventory do you get a percentage of the
sale of what sold
we wish we wish we get flat rate day day
labor pretty much okay
flat rate now if you were to put on the
auction like
my grandpa owned the auction of course
he got a percent a buy fee and a selfie
right so yeah he would get percent okay
but as an auctioneer we're just
independent contractors that makes you
really wonder if you had like bruce buff
or something in there from ufc or
something you had you know it's
time you know yeah like if you had
somebody that had that golden throat on
them it might oh yeah
gold would they get a little extra
that's passion
yeah that's what i call passion i mean
that's what i do every day
because i'm passionate about what i do
yeah and uh
yes i get paid well for doing it uh but
i i do it for the i mean i do it because
i love to do it and it's
funny it's fun it's never the same
really yeah it's different every day
yeah okay so that item gets up there you
got the item going now you started to
kind of lower the money enough and
monitor the crowd where i guess you're
taking this
you get a vibe of an audience same as a
comedian after a while you're trying to
tell where things are happening oh yeah
meeting people you really can man
it's weird you can almost read a group
of people right it's
you can almost feel little things of
energy oh yeah so you're reading people
you get a bid right
right all right you get that first bid
then where do you go from there start
going up
okay yeah you look for the second one
you know and now what if people do you
notice that people are feeling too
pressure like i'm a nervous bitter you
know so i would probably oh yeah we read
you
it would be hard for me to like make
that choice do you slow down
the verbiage and slow it down yeah or
speed it up and then they get nervous in
bed
yeah do that bro yeah that'd be crazy
man i'll lose a damn wife like that
have you seen somebody make a bed and
you oh you felt bad for them oh yeah
most definitely definitely yeah but
we're not there to babysit
yeah we're there to sell the car we're
there to sell cars and we want to make
sure everyone's happy but
you know i feel like if you don't piss
somebody off you're probably not doing a
good job
you haven't had didn't have a good
auction yeah wow so yeah someone's not
upset you didn't have a good option
really from one side you know right one
side or the other yeah yeah
um what is the schooling like take me
through some of the auctioneer schooling
and what are you doing there is there
you go in there and chant every day
betty bought her bought some butter but
she said this butter's better
bitter batter in my beer i mean just
tongue twisters all day long
hours a day learn how to learn how to
breathe that would be a hard one
yeah for 10 hours a day for 10 days so
it's not too bad i've breathed my whole
life but i couldn't imagine if i had to
really
section it off like that it might get a
little hairy
but what about um take me through a
couple of those yeah the uh
because everybody knew that growing up
like she sells c cells by the seashore
yeah so um you try to get your brain to
uh
think think before you speak before you
speak which is you think that's normal
but when you're going that fast
you know that's what the school really
does it's like teach your brain
to get up to that speed essentially okay
along with your mouth but
so take me through take me through one
of them if you even if you remember them
uh betty bought her boss some butter but
she says butter bitter if i put it in my
batter and make my batter bitter so she
bought a bit of better butter put it in
a bitter batter made her bitter batter
better so it's better so it's better
betty bought her about a bit of betta
butter dang
i used to be able to do it a lot faster
but i don't practice the tongue twisters
anymore
right yeah in school man you could
fly through it and so you take that you
you get these lessons then you go back
to class and are you doing them in front
of the other students yeah we do them
as a group so everyone stand up let's
see betty buttner
and we do this yeah climb two trees
tommy and tadamas i don't even know uh
yeah something like that tommy tatum has
took two t's time to
time it climb to the top of two tall
trees
along those lines and then uh rubber
baby buggy bucks
bumpers yeah that one's tough i don't
care who you are oh yeah i don't know
now
is there uh is there a type do some
people oil put a little oil in their
mouth or something before the deal
cough drops cough drop grease that wand
you know i'm a big cough drop guy oh you
are
yeah okay so you'll ride that lozenge
daddy i feel that yeah
because i'm wondering what i but it
clears your nasal out you know it helps
you breathe yeah
it helps you breathe and keeps your
throat slick yeah yeah i like that
slick throat that's key huh yeah that's
my bag
in my bag as my microphone and about
eight or ten cough drops
about lost my voice on tuesday yeah yeah
what were you guys selling
cars okay yeah we primarily do cars
every day
and that's and that world's growing i
mean i feel like the car
auction like i have friends like i don't
know if i just have friends that have
some money now or something but i got
friends sometimes then like i'll go over
their house like yeah there's buying a
car on my phone
somebody unseen i see a lot of people
buying stuff online
has the online business diminished you
guys's uh business
it's on twitter working on it yeah for
sure
there's these uh buckley the luckily
though there's
there's enough independent owners that
we work for
that that believe in the old-fashioned
the touch it feel it smell it come put
your hands on it
cater uh service uh hooter girls
food trucks stuff like that that that
will keep the business alive right the
experience yeah you're like independent
right the independent
mom and pop sales potentially you know
smaller ones but they're still pretty
big
and then you have the big corporate
sales um
you know that's i think that's the way
that they're going though
and so uh do you guys get is there
another
what's kind of like out to pasture for
an auctioneer because if you're a
comedian
sometimes you end up doing mate you'll
see a comedian ending up doing a little
magic
you know and we're not saying that they
put him out to pasture but that's kind
of like you know it's kind of the uh
it's the elevator down kind of from the
career a little bit oh he's doing magic
over there
you know which is fine no i mean yeah
magicians are comedians arch nemesis
that's always been a thing
right you know you'll see them talk
a lot and really hate each other as much
as they can but not say it
but um but is there a is there a side
hustle that the skill of auctioneering
kind of like lends itself to afterwards
or alongside of it
well in my my deal and his deal
he he does real estate on the side and i
play with cars
i mean i i i have a lot of free time
after these auctions too we get done so
we start at like nine
we get done like 11 30 or noon so we
have
the rest of the day okay we work three
to four days a week and that's it
and then we have just a ton of extra
time and is there reasons that auctions
take place in the morning is there
something to that
because the dealers have other things to
do in the afternoons right now there are
other auctions that take place in the
afternoons and at night
uh uh you know there's some night
auctions that cater
to the the mom and pop car dealers the
note dealers that that can't be there in
the morning right because they're
attending to their car lots
uh and so they'll have a night sale oh
yeah these are usually a smaller
and they're usually a more fun
atmosphere
you know yeah they'll have they'll have
coolers full of beer out there for them
and then they
you know they get drunk and buy
that they you know they're like
and they'll sell too that they like
i sold that that's cheap
damn yeah oh that's oh yeah yeah you can
see that yeah it's funny when you put a
little bit of liquor in there that oh
yeah
even i've just been like uh you know
sometimes somebody take you to a golf
dinner or one of those things where rich
people are playing golf
and then they buy you buy you know drew
brees signed football or something or
they get some damn
ready wayne like cooking you know
utensils or something people will buy
them for 25.
yeah sometimes it's just rich people
trying to show off oh yeah
we do some games and yeah and that's a
tax deduction too yeah we do something
else
that's true that's what they're doing
they're donating i see
so what type of event um what type of
what uh what do you do to prepare before
an auction like is there kind of a
series of things you go through or at
this point is it kind of just by rote
kind of
at this point it's really really natural
for me and and probably him too i mean
he's been doing it 10 years and
i i've been at at uh three to six auto
auctions a week for the last 25 years of
my life okay
every week so it's it's pretty pretty
natural
yeah we just kind of show up we we don't
know what the inventory is until it kind
of rolls through the door
we show up we have a meeting and then um
with the auction crew and the staff
and then uh we check our sound system
and that's pretty much it
yeah like a sound check kind of yeah
sound check and then the cars roll
through and everything we needs on the
screen
and we just sell them now do you get a
lot of
who are the type of people that bit that
buy a lot of things is it a lot of like
uh
do you see a lot of the same type of
collectors go to different events
do you see is it a lot of like
celebrities and rich people
is it just the lovers of automobiles
what type of people are bidding on
normal dealers just car dealers we
mainly work dealer only
auto auctions oh so we see the same
dealers so we see the same dealers so
like i could show you video clips in my
phone that where i'm calling out people
by name hey hey glenn do you need this
hey
hey hector hey this that and the other
because we we've known him for so long
and we build relationships with these
people because we see him week after
week after talking a lot of to them
too
yeah that's the best way yeah oh yeah a
lot of fun
we all we just talked and we you know we
talk because we learn people's
buying habits and we know what they're
gonna do
so so when something comes in that we
know they're they have to have it
yeah you know what i mean right up there
alley yeah we'll we'll you know we'll
we have fun with it oh yeah we make it
fun oh interesting so if i go to like a
used car lot or any type of car lot
right probably bought it at an auction
they probably bought it at an auction
potentially because i remember when i
was growing up my mom used to go to the
police auction sometimes she was dating
a man that ran
that on a car wash and uh
and she would go over there sometimes a
lot of times and
one time i think we almost had a a
police car for a little while like a
used police car
and uh they got it at the police auction
that was always a big thing the police
auction
yeah you know you'd always hear about
that and i guess that was cars that had
been impounded or something
and they were getting rid of a lot of
auctioneers drive those cars because
they
they can go fast because we travel a lot
that's the main part of the job is
travel
really that's the hardest part of our
job yeah it's getting just getting into
them
yeah and are they in big cities small
towns where are they usually big cities
you know san antonio austin dallas you
know there's
ton ton here in nashville i'm sure
there's probably five or ten
you know in this area uh memphis has a
bunch every big city probably has a
couple auto auctions all right we got
some show announcements here we have
some new dates
some shows have been added in cincinnati
in charlotte
we've added over there in durham north
carolina
chattanooga you got another one you get
a show you get a show
knoxville uh wilmington is still
available wilkes-barre
pennsylvania we added charleston we
added a show
and uh we also added shows new cities
portland maine
up there in uh in the black bear
continent
and burlington vermont i'm gonna come
and get that coat
so we'll see what we can do we also
added a new one in albany
and a new show in columbus um all dates
available theovon.com
tour make sure to get your tickets
through there so they uh
the prices aren't all jacked up and uh
and i look forward to seeing you
uh at the show sometimes i wonder if
there's something in the way of my
happiness and
and there is that's what the answer
always is and
and so a way if you're struggling with
that and
feeling like your happiness is really a
cul-de-sac
then uh then maybe you need better help
that's right
better help help is committed to
facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed
it's a counselor place you can get
counselors you can get
mental health help through better help
you can get uh facetime
phone text it's a way to communicate
with a therapist
if you if you don't want to walk down
there to the local brain center
where they they might electrocute her
put you on dilaudid
these people actually want to help
betterhelp.com
theo that's right join the over 1
million people who've taken
advantage of their mental health and
taken charge of their mental health
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and tpw listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
theo you know sometimes uh
debt is hellish you'll see somebody with
a damn hellish debt
you'll see somebody in a satan outfit
and you say what's going on they said
debt or you'll see him with a
wheelbarrow just
just carrying dead around it's weighted
it's heavy
thankfully when it comes to paying off
debt
and these high interest rates upstart
is here for you find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com theo
it's the fast and easy way to pay off
all your debt with a personal loan
all online we have some of the lowest
interest rates in the history
of the galaxy loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application that's
upstart.com
theo don't forget to see or use our url
go to upstart.com t-h-e-o
to see about managing your debt as best
as possible
let's get a question right here that
came in for you guys and uh oh
that's anthony you know him yeah
hey how's it going my name is anthony
out of san antonio and
the question for the auctioneers i had
was what's the craziest thing
that y'all auctioned off and how much
was it
gang gang gang anthony thank you bro for
the question man
now that's a good that that's a good one
yeah where does that land vasectomy
really yeah that clip huh yeah
and how did somebody have a free when
they had a yeah so it was at a uh
a gala event oh yeah and uh yeah it was
just one of those
items that they put up there i don't
remember what it sold for i'm sure it
was like
10 000 bucks or so but that was that was
the craziest thing
for sure just the backstory of some wife
and husband sitting there bidding on a
damn
yeah i don't want any more she's raising
the bed yeah you know and he's wondering
what the hell is going on she knows
she's planning on maybe divorcing down
the line so she's trying to
uh you know uh limit the inheritance
down yeah
crazy cars too but vasectomy was
definitely the uh
for me i think the uh one time i think
me and him were working together and i
think we sold
a yellow lab puppy for like 60 000.
oh yeah absolutely no way
was that seabiscuit or whatever damn it
was it was an event it was a it was a
fundraiser for a medical uh group and
i mean it was yeah it was in sellers
dogs dogs go crazy at those events it
was a puppy
i bet that mostly labs maybe it was like
a sound or
part of it you know what i'm saying from
that famous dog that died in that movie
sounder
but damn 60 000. i think the highest
priced car i've ever sold was i wasn't
actually auctioning i was working the
ring uh in houston texas
and it was a bentley for 330 000.
there was a i worked an auction in
amelia island florida
classic car sale and it was a car that
i think porsche and ferrari one of those
types of cars they built like two of
these cars together this was one it was
literally a rust bucket
950 000 is what it sold for
and i was working the floor the ring
like he was and why why why i think it's
just collector it was a collector i mean
they're
so rare there's only a couple of them i
don't know if that's it or whatever i
guess
i don't know i have no idea well in my
situation
330 000 bentley was in my mind
at dealer cost and they were gonna go
sell it for 550 retail wow
yeah man and we're talking about
this happening somebody spending 330 000
in a matter
a matter of 25 to 45 seconds
and so if that bid and starts out at 10
000 or something like
how quick like how do you know when to
differentiate between a bid you're
seeing on the floor
and a bid that's that you are getting
sent up to you from the ring
it i mean you're you're both seeing the
same thing
so you're both on the same wavelength
and if the bit let's say the bid starts
at 10 grand and there's eight people
down there just
just bid and bid and bidding you'll go
from ten one two
two and a half five you'll jump it up to
two and a half five seven and a half
eleven eleven two and a half five seven
and a half 12. i mean it
you know you you you read you read the
crowd like that just like
just like you do it gets exciting huh
it's very exciting
fast space too i think people like just
hearing people count remember they had
that um
you know especially where i'm from dude
if somebody could count how you thought
they were doing damn magic you know
uh i mean half my neighborhood couldn't
count yeah you know what i'm saying we
have people you told them about 11 they
know what you're talking about
you know what i'm saying yeah like after
10 they thought it had something to do
with satan you know it was real
just kind of novice numerical types you
know oh yeah um
what is uh take me through some of that
bidding like give me
show me a little bit of that magic you
know you want some magic yeah like if
we're bidding on something you know
um how do you know like what what are
some bids people do do people still do
the thing that like they touch their
face
and then like some people will turn away
from you and like
tap their leg or tap their head no and
then wink at you yeah shake their head
no winky to you
and they hide from each other yeah they
play games with each other yeah really
oh yeah
yeah it's fun and you you and you're
sitting up here yeah so you see all the
games
yeah that's something and it's it's oh
they mess with each other yeah
but you get involved with the games with
them totally they're yeah they're
there's some rivalries out there you
know you know there'll be people where's
the money where's the money and you're
like
i'm fixing to show you i got it now so
you'll know
you'll know and sometimes the audience
won't know that like who's doing it yeah
and guys over there in the corner just
oh they they play with each other so
much
and it's more so the the the experienced
and the skilled
dealers versus the younger newcomers
oh yeah that that that don't know
because there's there's there's always a
new dealer that comes into the auction
and doesn't have a clue as to what's
going on wow he's just standing out
front like this
yeah and you know the first two or three
months or an education
or an exit yeah because he's he could be
spending too much oh yeah
yeah i mean he can't get him sold if if
he doesn't get it figured out i mean
he's going to exit the business because
he owes a bunch of money
yeah and how much of it i know in texas
so many things are kind of like uh
is it is there any demographic to the
business to that whole bidding world is
it predominantly white is it mixed is it
latino
we have a lot of middle east it's very
mixed middle eastern too there's a lot
of middle eastern
uh and it also depends on the city
you're working in too right
like in the valley obviously uh lots of
latino people
we work in san antonio twice a week
latino people tuesday and wednesday
and then when i get done there uh i
drive to mcallen texas
and spend the night and work a uh
auction there on thursday morning
and it's it's mostly hispanic i mean
there's right there yeah yeah but it's
it's really close to the border
does it fee is it part of what kind of
culture do you feel like is it part of
southern culture is it part of auto
culture is
it part of livestock culture like where
does kind of auctioneering where does
some of that roots come from i know you
talked about the colonels
you know in the military and that's sort
of where that the name of that position
kind of came from but
can you tell me any more about how that
the the the fast talking
and and then separately like do you know
can you feel it all where that tradition
kind of came out of
you know i mean i know over there like
in across the pond in england they they
do it slow
oh i do it really slow like art auctions
and stuff it's a slow process yeah
you'll fall asleep
um but i think the latin root for
auction
is action so it's like all about action
so it's just a way to
sell a lot of items really quickly i'll
say and and competitive bidding matter
so like it's really a good way to get a
train ride evaluation pretty much
of what that product's worth interesting
because you got a bunch of people there
and they're bidding on it so
you'll get an appraisal for that for
that in my mind it's a southern culture
but you know there's there's auctions
all over the oh yeah
the world and all over the united states
new york everywhere you know
i guess because i was raised southern
right right
for me it's it's southern culture it's a
southern thing yeah
yeah it's interesting because i started
thinking about it like i i i
feel like there's some there's like a
mar a book with mark twain where they
talk
there's an auction or something one of
those stories i'm just trying to think
of where i first kind of learned about
auctioning or heard about it
and i can't really remember so then i'm
trying to think well what
yeah is there a culture that it fits in
with and then yeah it's a business it's
a way of getting people to do business
it is interesting to know that you could
immediately kind of get an idea of a
product
it could almost be anything right if you
got the right right crowd there too
can you start to know a little bit could
you guess almost like guessing
somebody's weighted affair like that guy
gets used to knowing the scale and
knowing
that the people can move most definitely
oh yeah like guess what
i'm in a bid for oh yeah because we know
what they did the week prior
yeah and we pretty much know the car
market yeah we know what ends up working
you know
that being said you know paying
attention to what's going on
and knowing the car market and and
remembering what that car brought
the week prior knowing who bought it the
week prior
uh it it it sets a stage you see what
i'm saying and so
so we kind of we can we can tell you you
know what you're driving out there we
don't have no idea what it is but
if we went out there and walked around
it we could give you a really good idea
of what it was worth
oh okay dang long as it's nothing crazy
exotic
right yeah it is not man it's a 2019
ford ranger
so um here's a fella right here that had
a
inquiry what's up theo it's your boy
steen here in louisville kentucky
a beautiful little evening i'm calling
in to ask a question to your auctioneer
buddy
mr auctioneer i want to know if you
think you have what it takes to make it
in the freestyle rap game
i know a lot of times auctioneers they
can think real fast
talk real fast i think it makes a lot of
sense that you could potentially be
freestyling over some instrumental if so
do you think you have what it takes in
that game
gang hang baby that's a good question
yeah i
love old school rap yeah and i practice
in the mirror
and absolutely no no me neither i can
count
fast that's it like if if the song was
about
numbers yeah right put it over a beat
but other than that now
you ever dress up like that sesame
street guy the count no
that uh twister song there was a twister
song that came out a while back
um i used to be able to to
to basically go along with that song for
like 30 seconds oh really yeah i thought
it was cool oh yeah i could see that
i i can pretty much saying my posse's on
broadway yeah
but you know i got to have that song
playing with me yeah yeah i'll tell you
who doesn't
um what about the la is there like uh
do people using uppers and drugs and
stuff like that to get that uh
you know to stay fluid out there on the
count course you notice uh you know when
they're out there
is there people using uppers no
not in my world it's a pretty uh pretty
clean-cut world i mean it it
you know your mind's got to be got to be
sharp yeah your mind's got to be sharp
you can't absolutely you can't go in
there you know
foggy and and continue to maintain work
you know what i mean you got to be sharp
and on your game
what's a mistake that you can make as an
auctioneer like what's a sell it for the
wrong
low the wrong floor miss a bid yeah i
miss a bid
yeah there's there's a lot of mistakes
for sure you can make a ton of mistakes
and it's a split set split deck yeah
it's fast decision second that you got
to make
and once you make it you got to live
with it and back yourself as soon as you
say sold i mean it's done
it's it's a legal binding contract once
you say sold
like i said earlier you know you're
looking into the you're waiting for the
online
the rep to tell you it's okay to sell it
and and you got a guy on the floor right
here and you're watching him you're
watching the computer
and you're going back and forth and the
and the the seller's kind of hesitant
and you're watching you're waiting and
waiting and you're wanting to sell it
and waiting and waiting and waiting
and then boom sold and then all of a
sudden the internet starts flashing
yeah well you forgot to look back up
there and i mean but you got to live
with it
yeah it happens um let's hear a little
bit of that lingo man how's it
so how how do you start it say it's like
something's about something starts at
thirty dollars you know
or is that a regular thing like thirty
dollars yeah i'm gonna do something we
usually we usually start
over thousands yeah yeah yeah cars
look i've been on a couple of beanie
babies before so i'm saying i bought
some real low market stuff we'll start
something at a thousand
yeah a thousand eleven to go to 12 13.
they get double 2 500 now five five five
they get doubled in all done i have
salt 2400 buyer number sean
too late sir you're out and so is the
the sound that you're making spanky is
that the is that the uh
ring guy is that the guy in the ring yes
okay yes so he's just telling another
bit is coming in yes
okay yeah so we just go up every time i
hear him yell
wow i only have to see him and it's
exciting for the crowd you know you got
some guy down here yelling what the hell
is he good
do some men bring a woman with them who
grudges them into it and now
yes
i could see it already man i mean i mean
look it does everything
you know if i'm with a gal i get the
damn artichoke dip or something i
wouldn't plan on doing that
you know i was just going for a couple
mains and neck so you know we're sitting
there
you know yeah now we're having you know
now it's
you know who knows what's going on so i
feel you yeah
it's interesting how that'll get a man
the freaking every car dealer likes to
walk in nice shoes
oh yeah they do huh part of that culture
huh it is that culture
yeah um now is there like a lot of
babies out there on the lot is there
like a lot of like uh
you know is there like a lot of like you
know big kind of betting broads
you know what i'm saying is there's some
like
like uh you know uh people that do um
cross tr drive across the interstate and
everything they have like a lot lizards
you know they got the ladies that come
to the door you know
yeah but is there any of that is there
any like kind of ladies out there any
freaking wager thoughts or anything like
that that are running around you know i
i will say that that most of the ladies
uh that that
are in the industry have my utmost
respect because they are very
professional
and they they you know they they learn
the business just like a man and they
buy cars
and sell cars just like just like the
men do right and they're very respected
and they're very respectful to us but is
there any like are there ladies that
come just to try and get
onto the or are there men that try to
come and just attach onto the ladies not
the actual bidders
but is there like a not really not
really not really
and and most of the ladies that are that
are there and most of the ladies that
come and buy
not not 100 but most of them are married
into the business
and they're there with their husband
okay and they're there buying cars
it's a family business yeah and they're
buying and selling yeah
you know for their for their lots i see
so you don't really have these ladies
that are just kind of waiting around
trying to like hit on the men or
anything like
that like you would it maybe no they
won't last long right
yeah the men will take them yeah quick
oh really yeah i guess i mean uh i'm
trying to think of what else i would
like to learn about that culture
you know what you have that came in sean
right here
hey man gang luke wait knoxville
tennessee
out of every 10 words
how many of them are an actual word
that's a good question like you know
like is there
is some of that actual words is it it
started off it started off as real words
uh or actual words um you know you start
off with a basic chant
and then it kind of translates into
something much faster and you kind of
shorten it
and you just kind of make it your sound
okay your
chance so my channel my chance started
at is uh would he give
would he give would he give would he get
what he give
two grand on twenty more mom a month two
to two but everybody know two and a two
and a three and a three and a four in a
five or five
now 500 on the round but everybody now
five on another right now six hundred
and now seven under the rainbow
but now seven seven seven would it give
would it give would it give but it just
it
it speeds up into something over over
time and practice
yeah interesting mine started off is uh
bit him and get them and get them and
bit them
wow looking heavy out the gates which
was my father's champ
oh really my father's chant was bit him
and get him and get him a bit him and
met him and get him
i practiced a lot with him with my
grandpa yeah as
when i was younger so i'd go over there
and we'd sit in his shed
and we'd have fake auctions oh until i
figured it out
that's why so i got his chance no he's
alive
alive and well i'm glad he's still alive
he's uh
does he miss it he calls every week how
was the sale how was the sale
checking how's the market i mean every
day he just can't help it
so how's the market and he's he's uh
80 years old and i have an
eight-year-old and a three-year-old oh
wow
and uh uh yeah i'm a label he's active
is he yeah yeah
and so i get out there my mom still
works at
one of the auctions that i work at to
this day oh that's cool she's a title
clerk
and uh yeah he watches my eight-year-old
three-year-old every day while i'm at
work
so they keep him busy yeah i bet that'll
keep him young for sure
right it's really one of the blessings i
feel like of having grandchildren like
that is if you're if your parents are
into it if you're if the grandparents
are
into it it really gives them a whole new
life as they get older yeah
my three-year-old and my father are best
friends oh that's cute
it's really great relationship that's
cool very blessed and fortunate to have
that
amen bro bit him and get him and get him
and beat him
yeah get him and get him and get him a
bit of him and get him now it sounds
nothing like that
no really well i mean you heard his
chance i mean that's what he's saying so
it would eventually evolve so this so
they get you with that intonation there
or what is that called
your chance chant now it's almost
interesting you had your grandfather's
chain it's almost like a
native american type of thing where you
know a song or a message that tone would
be passed around through
through a culture right he's actually
from missouri
and that that's i mean he went to school
there and he started working car
auctions
in 1974 selling tools and whatever and
then
i mean we you know we as a young
kid 10 12 years old i can remember
traveling around in the summers when i
wasn't in school
setting up tool auctions wow and we
would we would sell tools
cheap i mean china made tools that he he
would go buy in houston
and we'd go sell them in all these rural
cities and
i mean that was ebay that i mean that
was the original right exactly right
exactly you know i'm a true i'm in some
ways i'm a traditionalist you know i'm a
begrudging
someone begrudgingly moving into like
the modern world i feel like sometimes
because
my dad was so old when i was young and
so i think i was just
enamored with like older practices and
stuff you know and
slower ways of life and i really
it's so nice because everybody kind of
had a purpose there was so many more
things you could find that you could
actually
do whereas now things get with things
getting automated it's harder to uh
it's just harder to find some of those
spaces but it's good to see you guys
still are and maybe
hopefully do you feel like there could
be a rebirth of like
of the business kind of do you feel like
there's something new going on or what
do you feel like
like where's the future of auctioning
kind of uh i hope they realize
uh uh yeah you know the importance of of
what we do you know the the computer
can't do what we do
i mean the computer can count but they
they can't
they can't make relationships like we do
and make people
uh feel comfortable and warmed and
welcomed and and
you know it it it goes back that
computer's not going to say hey billy
are you looking for this mercedes today
right you know what i mean and and billy
likes to hear his name called over that
microphone
yeah you know what i mean billy likes
for the auctioneer to say hi to him yeah
you know and uh i i hope that
it continues in that direction to where
they see that that
we are a warming touch to the business
yeah
if that makes sense no i think it makes
perfect sense man it's like i think
we all are trying to figure out ways to
you know to make whatever the skills
that we have
uh still have value right in a time of
like you know when
electronica you know really yeah and
that's okay it's just what's going on
you know
right um do you have see with that being
said my
my uh i took my dad my 80 year old
father
into mcdonald's uh probably a year ago
and he he said hey what is that
i said that's a kiosk where you can go
order your food
and you just you just pay for right
there and you don't need to talk to
nobody he said
if i worked here i'd pour coca-cola
thing every day i try to fry it
yeah they just i just saw an article
last week or they're trying to do
automated through the drive-through
you know which is kind of crazy i mean
part of the fun of even driving
i think it said like 20 percent gets
placed or like 20 percent of the order i
think i saw an article
uh actually is correct right now yeah
yeah just mystery
yeah just which is what you kind of get
anyway yeah um we got another good
question that came in sean
hey theo this is kevin from sacramento
what's up kev
this is not a hostage situation i'm
actually just in my bedroom
um i saw your post about having the
auctioneers
there in studio i do have a couple
questions
um for the lovely guest you have there
have you ever had to use your your
skills
outside of the job for instance have you
been at the bar
have you been at the grocery store have
you been buying a vehicle
and it's just come in handy to have that
slick speak
dang yeah what's it yeah when is the
winners does it come in handy
or do people just want to see oh yeah we
get asked all the time for a lady at the
bar tonight
yeah oh yeah at the bar especially you
know really
friends uh you know the original
horribly like the original woodpecker
like a nightingale yeah
anytime you say i'm an auctioneer oh
really you talk fast
yeah you're a fast driver yeah you want
to hear it oh yeah
and then i'm sure a lot of the ladies
that probably leads them into wanting to
kiss get a little french action you know
a little tongue action is that a
do people want to test drive it a little
we're going to see tonight
there you go damn well you guys are
going to fast tongues
yeah somebody's not married i'm the
fastest tongue in the south really
i wouldn't say that but uh i try but
damn i bet you could put a worthers down
in a couple seconds couldn't you
i can do my magic on a cough drop yes
there we go
damn baby female cough drops only in
this man's mouth
boy um yeah someone is not married
they seem to be not married oh really
yes you're going through divorce huh yes
sir oh man
uh i'm so i've not been good in
relationships me man i'm struggling
either really i'm a bad picker when it
comes to that
i'm the bad per i think i'm just the i'm
just not good at it i keep picking
myself to put in them
trying to find a bad pick tonight oh
yeah there you go let's
do it might as well look there's a lot
of ladies in this tank
spank me right there that's how they
call them spank me no that's not why the
speaker
i got that nickname when i was uh uh
probably in
third or fourth grade because i looked
just like spanky the little rascal oh
yeah
i love the i love the little rascals
that's how i got that nickname
it stuck dude i'll tell you this story
so i was a huge fan growing up of
nickelodeon nick at night those type of
television black and white television
and uh and
so i was a huge fan of jerry mathers
leave it to beaver was the man right
so one time i got to play in this poker
card tournament in
oklahoma and it was like in rural
oklahoma at a casino and
so i get there and jerry mathers there
and i mean i had pictures of him on my
wall growing up and
and he was way before my time but i just
for some reason i like his name was
theodore in the show theater or clever
and that was my name so
there he is right there oh yeah and i
said hey
you know and i was so fired up man i
mean it looks
just like the kid still it's pretty
crazy
and i said hey uh i live it he
said i said hey you know i'm a big fan
you know
i was like he's like i live in
california i was like oh i used to live
in santa monica
and this is a little bit vulgar but he
goes i used to go get some in
santa monica
and i was like what like all horny
things i've seen this man
only as a kid and then he just hit the
perfect role model
he was the he was the perfect kid he was
the perfect one
and then he hit me with that and i was
like oh man
just ruined it yeah it's just crazy when
you always want your heroes to kind of
be a certain way and then they're just
immortals you know
or immortals i don't know which one is
what but um
but i look just like spanky as a kid
growing up and i could see that a little
bit too
that's where i got that nickname i could
see i could see it but you look pretty
young though
you feel pretty young i feel great yeah
and uh
did you know that uh that cam was gonna
be your son who was gonna be able to
have that ability was there another any
other children you had that
that you saw that could be uh that have
that possession
uh i have another 18 year old that has
no interest in it at all
that he's he's more of a hands-on guy
yeah uh
he he would rather tear something apart
and build it back up
uh but cameron took a lot of interest in
it at a very young age
you know 14 15. and that was a lot you
know back then
you know the the the scare of the
internet taking over
wasn't there at all yeah so he he had a
lot of interest in it and i knew that i
could
could help him you know and he would
have a good career in it right
and uh uh so the day he
the day he graduated he graduated high
school on saturday
and on the next tuesday he was on a
flight to missouri going to missouri
auction school
wow were you really mm-hmm so no doubt
no doubt
and you knew even young you knew when
you were young yeah i'd say i i really
got interested you know i was working uh
at my grand grandpa's uh auto auction
picking up trash and doing whatever they
wanted me to do
jumping cars you know jump start the
battery parking cars whatever
and then i think like probably 14 years
old he sat me down he said hey
you want to start working the ring and
so he kind of trained me up on it
and threw me in the ring and we started
working you know every tuesday and
thursday
in high school i would actually leave
class early i'd leave at noon on
tuesdays
and go to the auction i had uh i had a
couple teachers that would let me do it
oh nice yeah so i mean at a young age
for sure
i took an interest to it very interested
what is the course to how do you
graduate
the auction school um there's really no
test but after you so you go to school
and then you you get a certification
essentially and then you have to take a
state test to be licensed through the
state yeah every state is different yeah
and now is that a morning you show up
and you got to be able to really rattle
no it's actually written it's a written
test oh damn yeah so your certifications
for school
and basically lets you have the ability
to
take the test until 10 years ago you
didn't even have to go to school
but now most states have required that
you have 80 hours
of schooling before you're eligible for
the test okay
is there something is there any like
dark arts kind of involved out there
with auction
like where people are like putting
products up there like any kind of dirty
business that kind of comes through that
you're able to see that you keep an eye
on or anything that's happened over the
years not that you guys are pushing
yeah there's bad apples in every bit
yeah of course i've seen a lot of stuff
there's
janky stuff i i've seen people break
hood hood
release and and dump ice down in the
dash to make it look cold air was called
damn put a a radio uh
picture of a radio where in the hole
where the hole is
and sell it so that you know when you're
looking through the window it looks all
good it looks like the radio is there it
was a picture of a radio
dang and you get it it's just yeah
there's some shade there's some shady
stuff going on every once in a while
yeah for sure i could see that man
i could see that i'm trying to feel like
uh you know there there's there's
dealers that will go out and you know
unplug some stuff you know
unhook a spark plug so where it comes in
it's running rough and you know and
they'll buy it
whoever buys it usually yeah usually
whoever's the one bidding hot and heavy
on it is the guy that did it
that's awesome is there ever like a uh
has there ever been like a guy who was
coming up who was like a great
auctioneer and then something happened
to him like
like is there any like good lore or
anything in the auctioneer industry like
that
we have a good friend that that uh
you know was awesome auctioneer been an
awesome
awesome awesome auctioneer for years and
years and years
and uh uh just couldn't get off the
bottle yeah
yeah it happens man he was great too man
one of the best to listen to
one of the best had had a he had a good
fast chance
i mean just you know just really really
good and just i mean just couldn't get
off the bottle
yeah it's heavy man i had a friend who
drowned like who drowned last week
actually he was on drugs and
he tried to hide from the police and he
hid underwater
well and you can't do that i mean you
can do it but
it's a limited time right space and so
he died but
um yeah it's wild
and so that man passed away no no he's
still alive but he's not working he's
just not working he doesn't have any
jobs
yeah it's tough to see that kind of
thing oh yeah very tough
i had we were all closer from cops did
you yeah
i thought i was going to get away but i
didn't damn
that's what you did to put your lips out
of it no we me and some friends of mine
we
hoot some beer i don't know if you know
what that means yeah yeah and this is
you know i was probably 19 20 years old
many many years ago
and uh so the cops show up and i go back
to the apartment and i i said man i'm
just going to get in the pool and hang
out here until they leave
and uh so i hung out in the pool and
this is in january
and that's a weird choice when the cops
come out and see the pool when somebody
says no they
they they they never even came to the
pool because they didn't even think to
look in the pool in january so i go
walking back to my apartment thinking
i'm in the clear and
there i go and and they're like hey get
on the ground i'm like
what man i've been at the pool and
they're like it's january you
idiot get on the ground
yeah man i'm trying to think if i had
some good good ones with cops man i had
a friend whose car
something had happened to it speaking of
autos and there was some kind of
deficiency or something under the hood
and
when they rebuilt it they built the
seats backwards right
so the seat to the backwards was the
front of the car
and so he get pulled over all the time
you know cops was like oh you're driving
backwards and he's like well i'm not you
know it's just the way this car they put
the
you know they whenever they redid it
they kind of did it messed up or
whatever
and he'd always get pulled over and
busted dude dui or like
uh they would breathalyze him all the
time yeah you know but
people just couldn't get it in their
head that a man's driving a backwards
car
yeah not necessarily driving backwards
right but it's pretty keen to see
visually
so what's something over the years
that's kind of like is there
discrepancies down there in the future
yeah very much so we're always bumping
chests and really talking trash
yeah there's getting upset with each
other and i mean i've seen one car
dealer
get mad at another one and the one the
the had a flashlight you know them big
mag lights you know and then
this guy was gonna beat the out of
him with his flashlight and
the other dealer he took the flashlight
away from the guy
and beat the out of him boy i've
also seen another auctioneer
get upset with a dealer and i didn't
actually see it
i wasn't there but it's been a
well-known story for years and years and
and
carter flipped the auctioneer off and
the auctioneer came off the block
by the time he got down there the guy
had a knife and put it to his throat and
said come on big boy
yeah like i'm backing up now i'm going
back up to my block yeah
yeah wow i mean it used to get pretty
western you know
back in the day i'm sure but now there's
cameras and everything everywhere
and everybody's calmed down now yeah
that's much calmer much calmer
yeah you kind of missed that road you
know when it was a little bit of a
rockier road
mm-hmm easier times though
that's true rockier road but easier
times it's always it's always the good
old days
it always is huh when you're in it yeah
yeah yeah really
weird um did you meet your wife at an
auction
i did not i met my wife uh in san marcos
not at an auction
okay and that's where you guys are based
out of san marcos yeah neighbor awful
news
oh yeah new braunfels i've heard really
cool things about my friend uh steve
trevino is a comedian down there in new
york
it's great yeah and he's a great dude
and he's he loves it down there
beautiful up there it's great rivers
it's awesome beautiful place
is it you ought to come visit us yeah
i'm gonna come visit i gotta i'll have
to come down there and do a show at some
point
you know sometimes i have trouble
sleeping and focusing and acting right
which is everything that's everything
you can do um
and i wish there were a pocket-sized
guide you know that little
that little header to help me feel well
and act well and sleep well well now
there is headspace
if you have 10 minutes a day headspace
can change your life
it's your daily dose of mindfulness in
the form of guided meditations
in an easy to use app whatever the
situation headspace really can help you
feel better
overwhelmed underwhelmed agitated
um you know hurt yourself
headspace has three-minute sos
meditations
for you if you're overwhelmed
underwhelmed
um sidewhelmed everything headspace can
help
headspace is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits
600 000 5 star reviews and over 60
million downloads
i use headspace when i want to meditate
when i want to get back a little bit of
myself
from the busy world you deserve to feel
happier and headspace is meditation made
simple
go to headspace.com
theo that's dot headspace.com slash
theo for one free month trial try it for
free
feel your brain with access to headspace
full library of meditations
for every situation headspace.com theo
support for today's podcast comes from
manscaped
you know the time of year when you want
to get your body right and get you
you know everything right around that
luck around that luck knuckle baby
and you got to tighten it up and hedge
around and that is manscaped
you know the brand new lawnmower 4.0
and ultra smooth package is perfect for
you and the dad in your life
the manscaped ultra smooth package is a
three-step kit to help keep your family
jewels protected
with a crop exfoliator the cropped gel
and it's time to shave crop shaver who
take care of your junk get 20 off and
free
shipping by going to manscape.com that's
off with free shipping by going to
manscape.com
theo it's dad bod season time to get
smooth
let's get to one more question that came
in from someone
hola signor vaughn this is a question
for the auctioneers
uh i'm just wondering if there is like a
need to practice this is there any
application to the bedroom
um you know like quick quick in the bed
in the bed and bed bigger than the tank
and i'll plant somebody
fan fans you know what i'm saying i just
need to understand if it's applicable
and like how do you guys do it
gang gang yeah wendy yeah do women i i
we kind of touched on them but yeah i
guess women want to see the action a
little bit huh
they uh i don't you know
women like fast talkers yeah i do huh
yeah it's kind of hard to
yeah is it a fast is it
what are ways that you feel like the
ability to do
auctioneering correlates into
other type of like uh uses in life is
there any is there any time
yeah it's like it it's so fast pace like
it slows things down like
everything else is kind of like and it's
just opposite for me it's
it's it's made me very ocd i mean i'm
everything has got to be just yeah i
mean
everything's got to be just absolutely
perfect in my world or i'm just in a
in a like for instance he was telling me
they'd rather us be
late today than be early and i said
12 45 i'm telling him hey we got to get
an uber yeah you know we got to go we
got to go and then we're in the uber at
120 just leaving the hotel and i'm like
man i feel so awful we're going to be
late oh yeah he's doing math in his head
he's like
we get there in seven minutes and i mean
that's
that's just my world i mean and er i
mean
everything before i go to bed at night
everything is laid out and ready for the
next day
and i mean my schedule is set and i mean
everything's just got to be boom boom
boom boom boom perfect and was your dad
that way i'm just trying to know where
you got it from
oh i think it's i don't know i'm not
that way because it's interesting that
two different types of people then could
both do this job you know so it's not
really like
in the per it's that's just me right you
know what i mean that that right that's
just me
and you know uh in reality you know my
mother
is is a lot of the same way so i think i
get some of that from my mother
but i think a lot of it comes with with
you know just being up there and then
being in control of everything
oh yeah at you know so many days a week
you know yeah i can see that
yeah that control is a big thing man
yeah managing it and just
um just making sure everything's perfect
yeah for everybody involved right
you know what i mean and that's the kind
of way i live my life
yeah running smooth um
is there what are so how long is the
experience when you're up there on stage
you're doing an auction right
and you said it's in the morning starts
usually around nine
yeah and then how long is the action and
is it just straight action the whole
time are there breaks what's that
pretty straight action uh usually it
depends on how many cars you have
um you know different lanes will shut
down at different times because like
one lane will have 100 cars and the next
lane will have
you know 200 cars okay so it just
depends but yeah it's straight action
for
two hours give or take two to three
hours yeah and you ever auction more
than one item at the same time or no
no no there's different so like they'll
be like on wednesday there's 18 of us
okay and we all have our own lane and we
go and we start the sale so there's 18
of them so there's a lot of
dealers are running from lane to lane
like coming in late
trying to bid throwing paper uh flicking
us
off and cursing at us it's fun but yeah
it's fast
and uh that's real fun yeah people are
just running lane to lane trying to bid
on cars
and some lanes there's at some auctions
there's two
two lanes in one lane in the front of
the barn
there'll be one lane and then in the
back of the barn there'll be another
lane
so you'll have like let's say you'll
have a lane five car
come in the front lane six in the back
and then they both leave at the same
time
and then two more cars come in oh wow so
it's just it's a hot it's a lot of
volume
a lot of volume how many items do you
kind of auction we'll go through an
auction in one of those morning auctions
uh on wednesday uh we had what do we
have
16 1800 cars yeah no on tuesday we
probably had 800 to a thousand
800-ish yeah wow
and we're in a couple hours we're in
that ring bidding oh man there's tons
yeah especially on tuesday there's
wednesdays online
right yeah there's there's like each
lane like i think on wednesday in my
lane i think i had 120 people
online and then in lane you know uh
80 to 100 to 200 to 300 people yeah
yeah quite a bit of folks dang and is
there like a food truck out there or
anything
yeah yeah sometimes have food trucks a
little bit of a deal yeah yeah yeah
people come out
yeah there used to be a cable getting
hungry yeah so that was just
there to keep them there yeah we want to
keep them there until the sale's over
that's a trick
yeah that's wild man that's wild dude um
is it he ever walks off anything real
wild anybody anybody selling coffins or
anything like that anything like red
like any like a
treasure um one car dealer that has
that sells headstones at his car lot and
has a car lot and and and sells
headstones
on the same property that's pretty cool
yeah that's pretty cool one stop shop
well especially if he cut some brake
cords on those cars yeah
yeah you know what i'm saying that's
where people give you a deal
yeah um okay cool let's get into a
couple more of these questions man
people were really intrigued so you know
i was just driving through town about a
month ago and i drove by it said auction
auctioneer on the sign i was like oh my
god
i was like what are the all where where
where are these people
yeah where are they what are they doing
yeah so this is real fascinating man
just to hear about it
anthony my question's for the father-son
auctioneer duo
uh my question is can you guys read
really fast i'm not a good reader i
could barely read
but i'm not a great talker either so i
figured if i could talk
that fast i could probably read fast
thanks guys gang gang
hey baby that's a good question yeah no
not at all
i've gotten faster at reading but uh um
no i just learned how to read the less
you take in
yeah for me huh i just learned oh yeah
i'm saying yeah i'm slow reader too the
faster you read or the faster you try to
get through it the the less you
get out of it right yeah yeah that's
kind of how i am i think man
it's like i got to read it a couple
times yeah for sure if you read it too
fast you got to go back but yeah right
no i don't think that really equates if
you lose your track you're you're doing
you're
running a bid right is it every time you
lose your track
so what do you do do you call a timeout
screen the screen uh there's a screen up
there that usually helps if we
you know forget where we're at but
nowadays i mean it's just like like you
said it's like breathing it's like
second nature to us
you know you do it your sleep pretty
much but you get to thinking about
something else yeah you know while
you're up there and think about what
you're gonna have for a little bit you
know there's not a lot of action going
on on the floor you know and you
you get to thinking about something and
you're at 28 000. next thing you say is
eighteen thousand whoa
oh i mean twenty i mean twenty eight
thousand you just jump right back
there's a screen though that right
they follow us yeah okay and so like the
last thing we said is usually on the
screen so you got some support
yeah yeah just in case but it happens
for sure has any auctioneers ever been
killed or anything like that in the line
of duty
um not that i know of not in the line of
duty
nope oh that's good
that is good yeah let's get to another
question from probably some car dealers
that want to kill some auctioneers oh
really
oh yeah is there some inside work going
on is there like kind of like i'm trying
to bait you or take you out to dinner or
something no no
no no we i mean we just mess we miss so
much you know what i mean we see him
every week
you know yeah we see him every week and
we know their kids names and we're all
buddies
yeah we like to mess with them but when
we're up there it's it's straight
business
it is yeah i mean it's straight business
and we have a figure we have to get to
they may not like that figure but we are
doing our damn just to get to that
figure yeah right
our job is to sell the car right so
hey theo how are you doing my name is
joe from rockville america he's in a car
place
got a quick question for you and your
fast talking friends
yeah how much water you drink you must
get a sore throat
hoorah amen brother thanks joe man
yeah yeah you guys stay hydrated i know
you can see lots of water oh yeah really
that's for sure and are any of them
outdoors all of them are indoors
equipment sales some of them are
outdoors they'll like um the ones i've
worked before
uh they'll be outside but mainly there's
just like big barns
big shops and now what about people that
run running livestock is that a
different type of auction have you ever
done totally different yeah you're
selling by the pound
yeah okay completely selling selling the
livestock by the pound is totally
totally different
and y'all have beef with those people i
mean literally almost like no we haven't
we
have good friends there no they do
believe stocking yeah yeah own
livestock they do both you know and
they'll do both you know
most there's livestock auctions all
throughout the week but
for example a friend of mine that owns
one in gonzales texas
uh his is on saturday and he works
three or four sales during the week carr
sells during the week
and then doesn't does that on the
weekend um
but that's a totally totally different i
mean yeah it's
totally different i don't know and
that's for matin you know
you're like you know somebody you could
tell a dodge ram it in to sell a ram if
you want
that'd be cool but that that i think the
the the benefit of that why i would like
to buy something from there i think is
you get to you can mate it
you know and not you but you can have it
mate with something else
yeah like it'd be cool if you could have
a couple cars made yeah you know you go
park them somewhere in the garage for
the weekend and you come back
little baby car yeah a little baby car
scoots out it'd be cool wouldn't it yeah
i worked i worked a livestock auction
with him one time
and uh so that's funny
they're they're kind of they're up on
he's up on the block okay and then the
chute
is like down around him like a u-shaped
u
right and the cattle are coming in and
i'm i'm on the side where the cattle's
coming in
well this great big brahma bull i mean
1800 2 000 pounds i mean he's pissed
he wants out of there and this 70 year
old man is holding up this gate
and i'm like watching and you know i'm
not a cowboy in any way shape or form
and so i'm watching i'm like man i'm
going to watch this old man die right
here in front of me
well that old man jumps out of the way
and out comes that bull and takes
dead ass aim at me no and i'm running
through the arena trying to get away
from them
all these cowboys are looking at yeah
and i finally got locked up in the
office and then cowboys came and got
that cow
and man i was so scared god he
i mean he took dead aim for my ass
that's the worst when you think somebody
else is about to get it in this sudden
yeah about to get it
yeah that's a big locked in on them
that's a big shift in the head um
is there any good jokes you use when
you're up there is it kind of like that
or is it all business or sometimes you
can be on
the way i joke all the time all day
you know for instance i had a car dealer
that we have a really good relationship
with and
and uh you know i was selling a car and
it was on a red light
which is as is you know okay and i i
yeah we had one of those dude
you know and i told him i said come on
man take it as is it was missing
uh passenger seat for that story
so i i told him i said come on man be
like your wife take a chance
yeah there's some good jokes most of
them are just kind of like yeah improv
like yeah just short yeah short
one-liners jabs
yeah jabs at the dealers and yeah my
favorite joke i ever heard
uh it's a little profane but it's what's
the last thing you want to hear when
you're giving a to willie nelson
i'm not willing nelson
not my favorite joke ever it's not my
joke but god it's good
i mean it's just a good joke man we got
one more that came in for you guys
man have you ever been
caught raising the bid on an item
without any active bidders uh to reach
the reserve
and if so how did you handle that
situation yeah
uh he's got a little inside track there
does he yes yeah you know that man
no no no no he's our job
our job is to get it to the reserve you
know right we try to make that look as
good as possible
okay and what is the reserve it's like
the like what the what the
seller wants for the vehicle okay needs
for them to actually sell
okay so if it doesn't meet the reserve
it doesn't have to sell yeah we can put
it on call or
just no sell it okay and so i mean
it you know at the end of the day our
job's to get to there right so the least
no sales you have at the end of the day
the better
correct okay yeah correct so sometimes
you might
let it you know let that extra hundred
slip up there huh yeah
sometimes you gotta do what you gotta do
right um but you know
if something if they stop bidding or
whatever then we just explain to them
hey it takes
x amount of dollars a lot of time just
stop and tell them hey this is what it
takes to buy
that's what it takes to buy it and if
they can you know meet somewhere in the
middle or
we'll figure it out get it closer put on
a call but really we want to sell it
right there
yeah i mean you can't have a guy have a
damn seizure in the front row and he
wakes up and owns four volkswagens you
know
you can't you gotta um
let's hear uh some of your calls maybe
can we hear one yeah two grandma don't
join my mama
it's so much better like i have videos
if y'all want to watch videos
i mean to me it's so much better when
it's live and it's
and it's with speakers yeah with
speakers and
oh i bet do we have one of those all
right here we got a video right here
let's check this out so camera take us
into what you're doing here before we
start it
uh so this was i think pre-covered
no yeah pre-coven
and the screen behind you is the
uh picture of the car the guy to my
right is the rep
so he's going to be representing the
seller of the vehicle okay
um and that's pretty much it all right
and then there's a screen
another car so go back when you hit 375
you're starting a new yeah that's yeah
375 was the buyer number and then i'm on
a new one right now oh okay
so i'm announcing the announcements
right there what's wrong with it
oh okay so you'll say it has this or
this
that's awesome man so that's it you just
sit there and keep it cruising huh yeah
just cruise around with that safety vest
on what you have to have
yeah that's a that's a big bigger
corporate auction right there it's
they're big into safety and so cars are
driving through the lanes
and so they just don't want to get hit
so if you work at the auction or if
you're an auctioneer
you got to have them safety vests on
just in case you get off the block
and you're walking you know to go to the
bathroom they want the drivers the money
mouth they got to keep you healthy
yeah right there you go all right what
do we got here here's another video now
this section what's going on here
i'm selling uh uh new car trades new car
trade-ins
okay or or front-line old-age units oh
yeah
right there that's my nickname this is
uh actually in the valley this is in
mcallen texas
okay and uh i can't really tell you
until he starts the video
okay
that's
i'm fishing for money you are and where
are you looking where are the people
sitting
there see all those people right there
underneath those flags yeah
those are all car dealers those are all
buyers okay
and when i said detroit he's beating up
on us today
those were two uh corporate buyers for
big corporate
car lots and i was joking with them
right
and i was telling my my friend detroit
that the other buyer
was beaten up up on us today i see and
so these are the different lanes right
here i'm seeing
like this looks like i'm sitting like
you can see my block right there right
where that play
button is right the car's right in front
of me and then you see another
auctioneer right across the other lane
and you see his his uh uh
wrap clerk and then the clerk and the
car in front of him
and the car in front of him so each of
you guys so he does that car you're
doing this car do you go back and forth
no we're both going at the same time oh
really yeah it's like a sound wall
so it's all loud but once you step into
a lane you can hear probably that
auction
and then behind me there's two more
other lanes going as well
wow so there's a sound wall between you
and that guy yeah okay
you see where that above you see where
that uh where it says caution yeah
like right up above that is a is a great
big wall that separates
the two lanes i see that's where the
speakers are too they're well speakers
are up there and they're actually
uh that actually at that auction that
what that caution sign is hanging on are
ac ducks
hey man yeah yeah i like that cold air
um cool man so i'm trying to think if
there's anything else man i really feel
like i
understand a little bit more about the
world i understand that some of it's
kind of a family not a family business
but it
or a lot of other people that are in the
business they have a family member in it
oh yeah oh yeah it really is huh yep
yeah especially in the auto on the auto
side
primarily yeah i would say so um
most definitely all the all my auction
buddies like that the video he just
showed him
uh peyton crow his brother's in it uh
and then you got
their dad theirs in it and it's it's a
and then that
that guy that was working the ring for
me that he said jake long
his dad generation is a state
world champion auctioneer really yeah
now did any of you guys ever get into
the competitions or what's that like not
too much man
um i did one time when we were in waco
uh i never i have never ever ever had
any desire to do any competitions
and what is it like the competition take
me through some of it yeah
it's not it's in my personal opinion
it's not based or judged off what we do
on a daily basis
because you only get three cars
uh you only get you only get to sell
three cars and
i mean it it i mean you could get the
wrong three cars you could get the right
three cars you could
you could you could not be you know it
takes more than three cars to warm up
right so it's too subjective or
objective i don't know which one but
it's the one that's not
good yeah that one yeah
it's just never been for me totally and
just so what is it like not even that
you really i mean obviously you just
kind of
checked it out to see what it was like
but what is that compliment like what is
like
if i made that thing what is it yeah so
they have an auctioneer competition
no this is for automobiles but they have
other ones too they have state and this
one would be the world
um automobile automobile auctioneer
and so they have that they have a ring
man competition i was 18
i competed in the ring man uh i think i
got like 11th place
wow so there's nothing competing with
letting the auctioneer know
yeah yeah with the other ringmen yeah
with the other ringmen and then there's
an auctioneer competition
i think it was supposed to be in texas
yeah there's a team deal too they're
supposed to be in texas
and kovid came last year and i was
actually going to compete in it because
it was coming to texas
i think if it comes back to texas i'll
probably compete but other than that
i don't know is it fun though oh yeah it
can be yeah yeah it's a rush
for sure right yeah yeah yeah i mean
look a lot of those
a lot of com when you get into a
competition i think the same mistake
it's just
it's just different yeah i have friends
over on the last comic standing that are
better comedians than the friends that
have won it
right same deal yeah right it's hard to
get into a competition about something
like that right right damn i'm wondering
has ever been a movie about auctioneers
there needs to be i think it'd be great
there's be a show or something who's the
fellow
that had trouble with the drinking what
was his name uh
let's call him john okay that's fine
yeah i don't mean to call him out i'm
just thinking if it's a neat name
about a movie character no but he would
be a great movie
yeah he really ever seen that movie the
goods
it's about that car dealer uh i think
it's uh
you've seen it right man it's good yeah
it's a car dealer movie
i mean that's the type of guy that went
to jail on his wedding day hey man
i mean he got married and went to jail
yeah that one right there with that guy
wanna jail now yeah that's uh he's he's
a car dealer
it's a hilarious i think i have seen
that movie it's a hilarious movie
that jeremy piven sure is that's
hilarious i did comedy with him the
other night
really yeah he's funny he's a talented
talented man he's funny um
interesting i'm gonna have to see this
movie yeah it's good it's about it's not
about auctions but it's about car
dealers
and uh about selling cars yeah about car
dealers selling cars funny is he's a
one way i would definitely describe
jeremy is that he's a salesman
yeah he did a really good job in that
movie for sure
i'll check it out but yeah there should
be an auctioneer movie that would be
funny yeah i feel like
i thought it would be funny but yeah i
feel like we're really missing that
um so we do something here first of all
thank you guys for coming in man
thank you for having us yeah it's really
interesting to learn about your trade
and
uh and we do a thing here where we do
something for single moms we reach out
to a single mom and just kind of uh
just grant them a small financial amount
to just go do something fun with their
kiddo you know
so we uh we have a woman
you guys have a friend of a friend right
right and she's uh she uh
she raises her own she has a child that
she raises yeah two kids
oh nice two kids in waxahachie texas
waxahachie huh yes
dang okay well look man i've never had
my hatchet waxed but
i'd probably be willing to oh that's
good it depends
hey amanda yes sir how are you today
young lady good how are you good i'm not
a creep or anything like that um
so i'm just calling i work on a podcast
and we do a thing on our podcast where
every now and then we reach out to a
single mom and we just do something nice
for them
and uh somebody nominated you i'm
sitting here with two fine gentlemen
right here who are auctioneers actually
okay and they're from they're from san
marcos texas
um and we just wanted to uh
we wanted to make a just a financial
gift to you so you could go do something
fun with your kiddos this summer
um what yep that's all we wanted to do
just let you know that somebody's
thinking of you that's really sweet
oh well you're gonna make me cry well i
was raised by a single mom and i know
sometimes it gets a little tough and not
that it gets tough but just
you know we all want to know that people
are thinking of us sometimes when we
don't know that
you know so
what do your kiddos like to do
well my son plays baseball and my my
daughter
tries to play on his team too but we do
sports
that's title nine right there baby i
know
we do ball a lot i teach um
we're always together and we try to do
things on the weekend go to my aunts to
go swimming but um there's not
too much we do just being me so
it's a lot of work yeah it is a lot of
work sometimes well
we want to do something i'm sitting here
with some auctioneers so i figured
i would just kind of like i'm going to
have them just help me raise the amount
of money that we give to you so you can
go do something fun so
they're professionals so i'm going to
let these dudes start off the bidding
and then i'll raise it i'll be the only
razor
yeah a hundred i could have i got 100.
i'll give it a hundred now two because i
got a 200
round two and a three and a four yep
four back up again now six they get up i
got a six hundred theo
yes six seven they get up i gotta get a
seven they get up eight
they get up and get a nine to get nine
thousand yeah thousand dollar
one thousand theo make it even yeah a
thousand to get about 11 to get that
1100 all in all done i have oh
so thousand naughter to buy our number
theo
yup there you go so we just did it
i'm so thankful oh you're welcome it's
nothing uh
it's not about the finances or anything
it's really just about we just wanted to
let you know that
people care about you and that um you
know it's nice to know that
that's really nice to know that's hard
because it's time for me to take
compliments or anything because it's me
always putting
everything out there it's hard to know
when we got to do everything you know
it's hard
it's really hard i know and sometimes
when i have to be like that man i feel
like
and then it's hard for me to accept help
from others you know i'm just because i
don't want to show that side of myself
that shows that i need help you know
i really try to be independent but
inside i show face but
inside it's really hard yeah i don't ask
for help and i don't
expect any help i try to do everything
on my own but
it's hard well you're doing a good job
you know i want to let you know that and
uh
yeah just let you know that people love
you and are thinking about you behind
your back i know sometimes it's
you know we don't know that and uh and
that's true for you
so just wanted to let you know that and
and that's it
you know and um happy belated mother's
day and
yeah y'all go do something fun with
those rascals you know
we will for sure yeah okay thank you so
much for your time today have a good day
thank you you too thank you all so much
you're welcome you're very welcome
thank you okay bye-bye all right
oh that's nice man oh yeah that was nice
yeah cool stuff
yeah man it's uh i don't know there's
something that we all want to know that
people are thinking about us you know
for sure it's important um
or at least i want to you know i think
we all do in some way oh yeah
so thank you guys for nominating her
that's awesome she look you said she
lost her husband huh mm-hmm
man i think last year and that's your
wife's aunt's sister
that's uh no uh ashley's aunt's
good friend good friend oh well that's
awesome man well
yeah we're happy to be able to help out
and we're grateful for you guys coming
in today man and just being a part of
our lives and just learning helping us
learn about auctioning
yeah you know if i ever want to get rid
of something dude yeah i want to get rid
of someone i'll call a hitman but
something call an auctioneer yeah fast
fast baby fast baby yeah that's the key
um
cam spanky thank you guys so much thank
you thank you for having us
yep man you bet let's get one more call
on the way out all right all right
cam can you take us out yeah 20 grand to
get up i get a 20. now two pick it up i
get a twenty town louder down two and
four i got a six eight i got
about a twenty one thousand dollar
twenty one
yep twenty one not two bigger double
four six you get never get a a to get up
i get a twenty one eight i gotta get all
in all done
i have a good dog twenty one six buyer
number one two three
so now just floating on the breeze and i
feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece
[Music]
a little time
for me to set that parking
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
just
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
and these rails that i've been driving
on there